Those who have weak presentation skills
often don't have a lack of intelligence.
It's simply a lack of awareness of
habits that they've built and why
certain things are distracting to the
audience.
In this video, I'm going to talk about
some of the biggest public speaking
mistakes and the types of personalities
that you may witness. And if you feel
seen by this video, if one of these
characteristics identifies how you are
or other people you know, I want you to
leave a comment down below and let me
know. But let's jump right into it. One
presentation style that is particularly
weak is something I like to call the
reverse teleprompter.
What is the reverse teleprompter? Well,
for many presenters, they will have
slides that are projected onto the
screen behind them. But for some reason,
many presenters, rather than talking to
their audience, turning and facing them,
they feel the need to stand with their
back to the audience and read whatever
it is that's being projected on the
screen. But the problem with this is
that first off, by turning your back to
the audience, that is not very engaging.
But also, if you're just reading a bunch
of text that's on a slide, that's not
engaging. That's not interesting to
watch as an audience member. Instead,
you want to be facing your audience,
perhaps having movement through the
crowd, making eye contact with them. So
then, if you're wondering, well, how do
I do that without forgetting what's on
the slide? Well, the first thing you
want to do is ensure that your slide
doesn't just have a bunch of words.
Ideally, it has very few words. I'm
talking two, three, four, five words or
less. And it's mostly about visuals that
support or add to whatever it is that
you're talking about.
That imagery should simply signal to you
the general theme of what you're talking
about next. And when you build a speech
with pictures or chunks of ideas or
bullet points rather than word for word,
it allows you to be more adaptable. And
it doesn't matter if you perfectly
rehearse the same speech word for word
every single time or if it's a little
bit different as long as the general
information stays the same. One of my
favorite tricks is to have something
that in the industry they call a comfort
monitor. And in a big stage, that is a
screen below the stage that is showing
you the same slides that are being
projected. So there's no need for you to
look backward. You can simply look down
at that comfort monitor. But if you
don't have a big stage setup and you're
in a room like this, one thing you can
do is use your laptop. So you'd have a
laptop set up here as your own personal
comfort monitor. And that way the laptop
screen will have the same thing as
whatever is being projected and it's
connected through an HDMI. So that way I
can quickly glance and I see the visual
and now I can speak to the audience and
I can talk to them about whatever that
visual represents. And then when I click
to the next slide I can move this way,
take another quick glance and get into
the next part of my presentation. But I
want you to avoid the reverse
teleprompter. Don't turn your back to
the audience and read whatever's on the
slide. Another weak presentation style
is something I call the GPS voice. And
where people get guilty of that is when
they have notes written down and they
insist on reading the notes out word for
word verbatim and reading every single
word and sentence as it's written off of
the sheet of paper and not ever
diverting from their notes, rarely
looking up to make eye contact with the
audience because they don't want to miss
a single word and they want to keep
everything as it's perfectly written.
But that's boring. That's boring to
listen to. It is not engaging.
And this is something you should be
working on as a presenter is how do you
engage your audience? And so I would
love for you to detach from the notes.
I tried to throw that. Wasn't a great
throw. There we go. Detach from the
notes. Get rid of them and instead
practice your speech. Practice enough so
you know the general themes of what you
want to talk about. And if you insist on
using notes, if you're scared to fully
detach, just have bullet point
reminders. That way, as you're
presenting, you can give the information
and then if you lose track, you can come
back to that sheet of paper, which is
now on the floor, you can take a quick
little glance and remember what it is
that you're talking about. And now you
can move back up to the audience and
present that information. But don't be
the GPS voice that reads words off of a
piece of paper because that is not
engaging. Have you ever seen a presenter
who's giving a presentation and they've
got a lot of energy, but they're
constantly moving throughout the room
and they're back and forth as they're
talking about whatever it is. And maybe
they're trying to be motivational and
hype up the audience and they're they're
really passionate about what they're
talking about.
This isn't the worst presentation style,
but it's something that I like to call
the Roomba. The Roomba is constant
movement. Constant movement around as
you're talking, moving around the
audience. And why I say it's not the
worst presentation style because it
actually indicates a lot of confidence
to be able to move that much as you
present and constantly be energizing.
And it's not the most boring thing to
watch. However,
I would argue that a better presentation
style incorporates strategic movements.
So from now from time to time, pausing
in a spot when it makes sense to do so
and really allowing that thought to sink
in and then as you move to the ne next
idea moving physically to that space and
engaging this side of the room making
the eye contact and allowing that to
land.
This style is more intentional. It's
more powerful. But if you are the
person, if you're guilty of being the
room but constantly moving around, know
that that's not the worst thing. But I
do think that there's a better way that
you can present which is more purposeful
and less distracting. One of the things
that happens when we give presentations
is that our heart rate increases a lot
and we get some level of nerves. And for
many people, they come up to the front
of a room or a stage and they talk
really quickly because that heart rate's
going. And uh a lot of um filler uh
words will uh um come into place because
the heart rate's going and we feel like
we need to be talking so quickly and any
silence feels awkward. And for these
types of people, these types of
presenters, it's something I call the
auctioneer. The auctioneer is somebody
who is talking really quick because they
have all that adrenaline, all that
energy and they want to just keep going
and maybe there's the nerves and they
just want to get through this
presentation as quick as possible,
but you want to incorporate more pauses.
You want to slow down slow down the
pacing of the presentation. And one
really clever trick to do this is when
you're practicing for a speech, practice
with an elevated heart rate. That is
going to simulate the environment, the
experience that you feel when you
actually are in front of a room full of
people. And by doing 50 jumping jacks or
running on the treadmill for 10 minutes
before you practice a speech, you're
going to get that heart rate up. And
that is going to be very similar of what
you're feeling when you do step in front
of the audience. So if you've practiced
with an elevated heart rate and you've
slowed down the pacing successfully,
you're going to find on the day of your
speech, it's much easier to slow down
and allow the pauses.
Pauses let the audience think.
They allow ideas to set in.
And this comes back to the purpose of
why you're giving a presentation. You're
not standing up here to get through it
as quickly as possible. You're standing
up here to teach the audience something,
to give them some form of value.
And strategic pacing helps you do this.
There is a common presentation type that
I like to call the wandering eyes. And
the eyes often wander two places. They
wander down or they wander up. And when
they wander up, this is often speakers
thinking, trying to recall, looking up
in their memory, trying to figure out
the next thing that they're going to
talk about, or they're telling a story,
and they're trying to remember the
details as they're doing so.
The other alternative for wandering eyes
is that they look down. And this might
indicate a lack of confidence or there
may be that thinking element as well,
but these speakers are often trying to
muster up the courage and they're really
focused on what they're saying and maybe
they're a little bit scared of making
any form of eye contact. But the problem
with this and the problem with that is
that it's not eye contact.
This is eye contact. And when you look
at your audience in the eyes, you create
a level of accountability
because it's hard as an audience member
when the speaker locks eyes with you to
then be distracted because you know that
speaker, especially if they're good at
continuously making eye contact with the
room,
you know that they're immersing you in
the story. and you don't want to be rude
or disrespectful or on your phone or
talking to your neighbor because you
know you're being acknowledged as an
audience member. It's far easier to
ignore a speaker who is stuck behind a
lectern or constantly looking down than
it is to ignore a speaker who is moving
throughout the room and making eye
contact. And so if you can keep that
attention with the eye contact, there is
a much better chance that your audience
is going to remember and retain the
message you are teaching them. The final
speaking presentation style that I don't
think is very effective is something I
call the scenic route. And this is the
speaker who is talking about an idea and
then suddenly diverts to something
completely different. who's talking
about. All right, so let's jump into our
goals for the remainder of this year,
what we hope to accomplish as a company.
But before I do that, I actually want to
backtrack and I want to talk about last
year and some of the things that went
really well. And I think as a company,
especially John over there, let le let's
talk about John for a second because
John did something really impressive
last year and a project that he was
working on and this took our company to
the next was it Susie was involved in
this as well. Right? So we'll come back
to that later. I'm going to touch on
that. But for now, let's get back to the
original point that I was talking about,
which is the goals for next year. And if
you're trying to follow the cadence of
what's happening, it's like you started
here and you've been taken on this crazy
journey and maybe you land at the final
destination and maybe you don't, but the
speaker is constantly moving on to
different things. And the challenge with
that as an audience member, it's very
hard to follow the point and understand
what it is that is the takeaway from
this presentation. If constantly the
speaker is just taking the audience in
different directions,
there's less likelihood they will retain
the information.
Instead, as a speaker, I would love to
see some structure that is purposeful so
that the audience does take something
away. What is your most important
message that you want them to leave
with? And you should be intentional
about that when you're presenting. And
this isn't to say you can't be
adaptable. I think adaptability is a
very important skill and something that
the best speakers are able to do.
But for the most part, a formal
presentation, a formal speech,
make sure it's structured. Structured in
a way that you know your audience is
going to have some tangible takeaways. I
hope these speaking personality,
profile, styles were interesting to you.
Do any of you feel seen? Are any of you
falling into one of these categories? If
so, let me know in the comments. I'd be
really curious. I've been guilty of a
few of these different styles over the
years, especially the auctioneer where I
speak too quickly and a practice
presentation that takes me 10 minutes
when I practice only takes me five
minutes when I'm in front of a room of
people. So, this is something we have to
constantly work at and try to improve
upon. And speaking of which, my YouTube
channel, as you know, has a ton of video
content to help you become a more
confident communicator. But if you want
to take that to the next level and you
want to work with me, I have a stand
store link below with several offerings
of how I can help you be a more
confident communicator, check out my
Stan store. I also run speaker
accelerators periodically. So, comment
below if that's something you might be
interested in.
Besides that, the best way you can
support me and my channel is by
subscribing to my channel. This helps
more people discover this content and
help them with one of the most common
personal fears in the world, which is
public speaking. Because I'd love to
have many more confident communicators
out there in this world sharing their
important messages. and check out the
video that YouTube is recommending for
you right now.